[Musica]
è una storia
di una presa di coscienza la mia
è la storia di un percorso che mi ha
portato a rivalutare completamente il
mio rapporto con gli animali in
particolare con gli animali non da
compagnia
Diciamo che spero che queste mie parole
siano di ispirazione per tutti voi
allora Tutto è incominciato in questo
cinema al cinema Sant'Orsola di Bergamo
un locale che io ricordo terribilmente
fumoso perché eravamo nel 1946
e nei locali era permesso fumare
e stavo venendo un film meraviglioso
Bambi che tutti ricorderete non avevo la
minima idea di cosa significasse la
parola etica D'altronde Avevo 8 anni vi
confesso che non mi interessava neanche
più di tanto
però in questo film
C'era una scena che mi ha colpito molto
e mi ha insegnato tanto la scena non è
quella che tutti voi vi aspettate cioè
quella di della mamma di Bambi che muore
ma quella in cui il padre di Bambi
vedendo un fil di fumo che si solleva
dal fondo della Valle dice al figlio c'è
l'uomo
Ecco queste parole per me furono
terrificanti cioè io capii in un attimo
tutto il terrore che poteva inculcare
negli animali la sola presenza dell'uomo
furono parole che per me furono
imprinting che segnò tutta la mia vita e
anche buona parte del mio lavoro
un'altra cosa importante che mi ha
insegnato il film è stata quella di
avere un altro punto di vista un diverso
punto di vista mi sono accorto che
cambiando angolazione molte cose
cambiavano io l'ho rappresentato con un
terzo occhio perché mi sembra anche
giusto
guardando le cose ad esempio osservando
L'uomo da grande distanza non è più
l'uomo
il solito uomo Il dominatore
dell'universo Come pensiamo ma diventa
un piccolo piccolissimo animale
oltretutto molto pericoloso e che
commette tantissime errori utilizzando
questo punto di vista particolare in
questo caso tecnicamente lo chiamiamo un
campo lunghissimo
ho realizzato dei film Innanzitutto
sperimentali Ma poi un cortometraggio
che si intitolava alla Vita in scatola e
che mostrava la vita di un uomo dalla
nascita alla morte Ecco il film mostrava
l'uomo talmente piccolo che praticamente
era un insetto e diventando un insetto
perdeva e connotazioni personali e le
sue azioni e i suoi movimenti
acquistavano un'importanza
che secondo me dal punto di vista
critico diventavano interessantissime un
altro film in cui ho usato un'altra
angolazione è quella in cui ho mostrato
un gatto che si muove in una casa Ormai
decrepita e in via di distruzione E
ricorda con nostalgia tutte le i momenti
belli della propria vita e io penso che
fu proprio in questi film realizzando e
pensando scrivendo le storie di questi
film che pose i primi tasselli per
diventare vegetariano però il salto di
qualità diciamo così avvenne quando per
puro caso in famiglia entrò una
pecorella era appena nato aveva ancora
il cordone ombelicale io poi la chiamai
Belen Perché suona bene
Allora
io le pecore non le ho mai tenute in
considerazione particolari le
ricordavano i sogni quando si contano ma
non le avevo mai osservate con
attenzione Vedendola crescere nel
salotto di mio figlio che ha 50 metri da
casa mia ho visto quale intelligenza
quale sensibilità avesse
giocava con noi intelligenza perché
riusciva ad aprire due chiavistelli
piuttosto complessi con la bocca ma poi
ho visto un altro essere ho visto un
cane Ho visto un gatto visto ho visto un
essere del tutto per tutto simile a noi
contemporaneamente avevo degli amici che
tenevano in casa degli animali non
prettamente da compagnia chi aveva
un'oca che un coniglio Addirittura uno
Aveva un maiale che oltretutto si è
rivelato più pulito e più
ubbidiente di un cane
un'altra amica una fotografa Silvia
Amodio Teneva una gallinella e l'ho
vista io con i miei occhi riconosce i
colori distinguere gli oggetti
era una cosa fantastica era una gallina
ed era veramente intelligente Allora a
questo punto mi sono chiesto Ma questi
animali animali non di compagnia che non
vengono assolutamente considerati da
nessuno oggi come potrebbero dimostrare
di essere sensibili gli esseri
intelligenti la mia la mia Belen se
fosse se avesse continuato la sua vita
normale sarebbe finita in un gregge di
questo genere
Allora come potrebbe lì dentro di
mostrare di essere sensibile
intelligente di avere una personalità
non potrebbe mai nessuna maniera così
come non possono farlo le centinaia di
migliaia di animali che sono chiuse nei
negli allevamenti intensivi e che non
sono altro che numeri sono dei
prigionieri dei condannati a morte ma
non potranno mai dimostrare di essere
qualcuno e non qualcosa e fu proprio
questa constatazione
a spingermi a cambiare direzione Quindi
da quel giorno deciso che non avrei più
messo nel mio piatto degli esseri
senzienti del tutto per tutto simile a
me Ma oltretutto questo importante non
se ne parla abbastanza dei bambini
perché gli animali restano sempre per
tutta la vita dei bambini non crescono
psicologicamente non evolvono
loro unico desiderio è giocare e voler
bene a chi li Protegge e quindi
ho deciso di diventare vegetariana vi
assicuro Non è difficile più facile che
smettere di fumare molto più facile però
c'era un problema c'era una cosa che mi
angustiava Come mai Ero diventato
vegetariano dopo così tanti anni fin nei
conti della visione del film Bambi
all'arrivo di Belen Erano passati
decenni
E ho scoperto ragionando che io in tutti
quegli anni avevo vissuto dentro un buco
nero o il buco nero una mia invenzione
intendiamoci però rende bene l'idea il
buco nero per me è una zona oscura una
zona
in cui noi ci muoviamo come dei
sonnambuli cioè facciamo delle azioni ma
non sappiamo cosa facciamo esattamente
in questo in questi buchi neri diciamo
così dominano alcune parole ci sono
anche parole belle simpatiche piacevoli
ma sono pericolosissime questi sono
parole che vi incatenano al fondo di
questi buchi neri voi tutti sapete che è
più facile accettare una cosa nuova che
riuscire a fuggire da una vecchia Ecco
il mestiere di queste paroline è proprio
quello fare da guardiani e impedirvi di
fuggire da queste zone i buchi neri si
sono sempre stati nella società
oltretutto sono quelli che rallentano il
progresso
lo fermano tante volte ad esempio lo
schiavismo era un buco nero in quel
periodo era normale era accettato da
tutti la sottomissione della donna e la
dominazione dell'uomo era accettata da
tutti era normale si era sempre fatto
così perché è cambiare Addirittura il
geocentrismo prima dell'arrivo di
Copernico per migliaia di anni era
ritenuto accettabilissimo da tutti La
Terra era al centro dell'universo ora
uno dei buchi neri più grandi che
abbiamo in questo momento è quello in
cui ci sono questi poveri animali che
non sono considerati da nessuno
che sono praticamente invisibili e che
si ci si ricorda di loro solo quando
dobbiamo sfruttarli o dobbiamo mangiarli
Io per fortuna sono riuscito ad uscire
dal mio buco nero personale chiamiamolo
così ed è successo quando ho letto che
vegetariani e vegani nel mondo erano
circa 7%, Voi direte una cifra piccola
minima di nessuna importanza
in realtà stiamo parlando di 500 milioni
di persone ora voi mi capite 500 milioni
di persone sane vegete che vivono
perfettamente che tra loro hanno e hanno
avuto delle delle personalità culturali
di altissimo livello Cito solo Einstein
o Margherita Hack per dirne due che nel
campo sportivo hanno delle persone che
vincono le olimpiadi che primeggiano in
tutto il mondo per salute Per velocità
per forza per agilità Io credo che
questa sia la prova più indiscutibile
che non ci sia la necessità di mangiare
carne se lo facciamo è solo per un
nostro piacere personale e potrebbe
anche andar bene Il problema è che per
questo nostro piacere per questo
gradevole gusto in bocca noi facciamo
uccidere in un anno siamo noi che li
facciamo uccidere quindi siamo noi
mandanti facciamo uccidere 80 miliardi
di animali
non so se vi rendete conto Questa è la
cifra che rappresenta il più grande
crimine dell'umanità
Tanto è vero che una cifra così
incredibile che per renderla portarla
più vicina alla mia mentalità ho fatto
un calcolo e ho scoperto che
praticamente ogni due minuti vengono
uccisi tanti animali Quanti morti di una
bomba atomica di Hiroshima a me queste
cifre spaventano terrorizzano Eppure
vedevo che il resto del mondo continuava
tranquillo imperterrito insensibile
allora ho capito che Qualcosa dovevo
fare ma cosa Potevo fare Ero solo
l'unica arma che avevo era la matita e
quindi ho deciso da quel giorno di
cercare di provocare di scandalizzare di
attirare l'attenzione e far capire
questa gente che esiste un'altra realtà
oltre alla loro E allora usando la
matita Ho deciso che da quel giorno lo
sto facendo anche adesso ho deciso di
combattere per gli animali soprattutto
da reddito
e ho deciso di difenderla loro dignità
la loro intelligenza la loro sensibilità
il loro diritto di vivere perché tutti
gli esseri viventi hanno diritto di
vivere Ho deciso di difenderli dalla
cultura dalla letteratura dal cinema
dopo tutti i mezzi di comunicazione
perché insistono nel dire che gli
animali sono stupidi cattivi aggressivi
feroci nemici dell'uomo è vero
esattamente il contrario siamo noi
nemici degli animali Siamo noi che
invadiamo il loro territorio se qualche
volta loro aggrediscono lo fanno per
difendere il loro habitat per difendere
la loro prole per cercare cibo che noi
gli portiamo via ho deciso di difenderli
dal linguaggio corrente perché se voi ci
pensate ogni giorno sentiamo dire o
diciamo delle frasi stupide delle frasi
soprattutto false
e gli animali non possono certo
difenderci non difendersi non hanno la
parola ho deciso di difenderli anche dal
fatto che un animale intelligente
sensibile diventi semplicemente una
forbita
parolina sul menu di un ristorante o una
lunga fila di confezioni di plastica
tristissima perché per me sono tristi
perché mi ricordo nel cimitero degli
animali in un Supermarket e la cosa più
triste di tutte è che questi animali
invece non solo sono straordinari Ma
hanno dei poteri incredibili dei
superpoteri che farebbero impallidire i
nostri tanto gettonati supereroi che
peraltro sono frutto della Fantasia sono
nati dal nulla Pensate che un Albatro
può volare per mesi senza mai posarsi a
Tel a terra con le due metà del cervello
che usa turno
ne spegne una e usa l'altra cose da
fantascienza pensate che un'aquila a tre
chilometri riconosce un coniglio noi non
vedremo neanche un elefante pensate al
naso di un cane che possiede 220 milioni
di cellule olfattive noi ne abbiamo
cinque ma perfino la più umile
umilissima
anguilla che praticamente è percorre
5/6.000 km in un oceano sconosciuto
perfettamente Noi siamo capaci di
perderci sull'automobile con un GPS in
30 km
E così ho deciso di fare qualcosa di
fare delle vignette di parlare di questo
di difenderli di far capire che il
problema è grave c'è
e per farvi darvi un'idea di come lavoro
e di cosa sto facendo ve ne mostro
alcune
a volte mi capita di invertire la
situazione Cioè mostrare la realtà dal
loro punto di vista che è molto diverso
la loro realtà è molto diversa dalla
nostra
quando posso ovviamente uso l'umorismo
l'umorismo È un'arma formidabile perché
quando una persona sorride di una
vignetta significa che si riconosce e
questo lo spinge a riflettere e io
voglio proprio che lui rifletta
cerco di far capire all'uomo quale
terrore provochi negli animali la sua
sola presenza per farlo capire a noi
umani ho immaginato che
uno di noi forse seduto a vedere la
televisione improvvisamente Nella stanza
gli entrasse Frankenstein magari non
farebbe nulla se scenderebbe sulla sul
divano a vedere la televisione insieme a
lui
ma se gli gira se potrebbe stritolarlo
in pochi secondi questo non lascia
tranquillo l'uomo così come un animale
selvatico non sarebbe tranquillo vicino
a qualsiasi tipo di umano
combatto l'arroganza dell'uomo che si
crede il re del creato in realtà è solo
un animale come tutti gli altri e se
commette oltretutto tanti errori lo fa
per avidità di denaro per
il proprio ego e per vanità diciamo così
a volte mi tocca mostrare delle
situazioni scomode antipatiche però
sento che bisogna è necessario farle
altre volte esagero e questo crea delle
situazioni totalmente nuove e sono
interessanti perché la situazione nuova
attira di più l'interesse del lettore ed
è portato a memorizzarlo maggiormente
altre volte ribalto la situazione
soprattutto quelle normali perché credo
che siamo tutti responsabili di ciò che
sta succedendo ora in questo periodo sto
tornando al cinema e quindi sto
realizzando un cortometraggio in cui
vorrei mostrare tutte le migliaia di
specie animali distrutte dall'uomo è una
specie di campanello d'allarme per
mostrare che
Stiamo andando nella direzione sbagliata
e questo proposito mi viene in mente una
bellissima frase di controllorence che
dice l'anello di congiunzione tra la
scimmia e l'uomo civilizzato esiste
siamo noi è molto bella e si fa capire
che abbiamo ancora molta strada da
percorrere
Ecco io sono arrivato a queste
conclusioni coi disegni col mio lavoro
voi potete se arrivarci con la Col
sentimento con la sensibilità
Se vi capita di vedere qualche animale
magari in condizioni disagevoli Provate
a usare il terzo occhio di cui ho
parlato prima Provate a mettervi al
posto di questi animali a vedere la
realtà come la vedono loro vedrete che
cambia totalmente e forse sarete portati
a comprenderli magari anche ad aiutarli
questi immedesimazione anche un nome
tecnico si chiama empatia
Io penso che sia uno strumento
straordinario per migliorare il mondo e
soprattutto per restituire agli animali
la dignità e il diritto di vivere che
ogni essere vivente si merita Grazie
[Applauso]
Che meraviglia Bruno
Grazie davvero per aver accettato il
nostro invito a Telex Brescia Grazie
innanzitutto ti chiediamo Come sta Belen
credo che sia molto bene sempre più
grossa per tutti
chi lo segue sui social lo sai da anni
Insomma che vede le avventure di questa
fantastica pecora No a parte l'umorismo
che è un po' la tua chiave di lettura di
tutto oggi ci hai regalato anche la
chiave dell'empatia e per essere uno che
afferma di essersi sempre espresso solo
disegnando e questo solo è veramente tra
virgolette cioè sbalordito con con la
tua oratoria Grazie
Diciamo che ho scoperto che anche la mia
veneranda età Posso fare qualcosa di
nuovo e questo è già uno stimolo
interessante non l'avevo mai fatto
parlare in pubblico non è il mio
mestiere
grazie Per fortuna che che l'abbiamo
fatto questo questo Tex Ma ci hai anche
nominato un tuo nuovo lavoro un tuo
nuovo film e ti chiedo se hai voglia di
raccontarci un po' di più perché
ricordiamo tutti anche
tanti tuoi lavori ma anche tante
presenze televisiva in ad esempio con
Quark con Piero Angela cioè la tua opera
è un'importanza artistica molto
importante ma anche un'importanza
in un ambito divulgativo di una
televisione che ci ha educato anche nel
corso dei decenni quindi siamo molto
contenti di sapere che sta arrivando
questo nuovo lavoro e se hai voglia di
parlarcene un po' non so dirti nulla
perché quando siamo in fase di
preparazione anche per me un mistero
sono io il più curioso di vedere il
risultato più di voi Diciamo che
adesso incomincia al lavoro in cui
arrivano i collaboratori finora ho
lavorato io lo storyboard sceneggiatura
o perlomeno io e Diego Zucchi
Ma da adesso in poi incominciano
arrivare i grossi calibri cioè
scenografi animatori effetti speciali
quindi
è non è niente di particolare voglio
solo sollevare l'attenzione sul problema
di cui ho parlato adesso perché reputo
che sia importante lo diventerà sempre
di più Grazie davvero grazie a voi
[Applauso]